CAMPAIGN.
HE WILL ADDRESS THIS PACKED
HOUSE, AND THAT'S WHAT FIGURES
TO BE THE PRESIDENT'S SIGNATURE
ISSUE.
IMMIGRATION AND BORDER SECURITY.
AIR FORCE ONE, AND WILLIAM LODGE
AND US IS BEYOND THE U.S. BORDER
IN MEXICO.
>> WITH ROADBLOCKS AND
CHECKPOINTS, NATIONAL GUARD AND
IMMIGRATION AGENTS ARE STOPPING
VEHICLES AND HUNTING FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
FOLKS ARE ALSO STAGING ALONG THE
GUATEMALA BORDER.
>> WE ARE WORKING WITH THE U.S.,
AND MEXICO'S POLICY TODAY IS
LIKE NIGHT AND DAY COMPARED TO
SEVEN MONTHS AGO WHEN IT OFFERED
HUMANITARIAN VISAS, WORK PERMITS
IN HEALTH CARE.
PLEASE POLICE FILLED UP BUSES
AND TRUCKS WITH IMMIGRANTS
HEADED TO THE U.S.
>> AND, BACK IN THE SALVADOR,
YOU CAN'T EVEN LEAVE RIGHT
THERE.
>> AND SHE CAN'T GO BACK BUT
OTHERS HERE ARE TRYING.
>> .
HUMAN SHELTERS ARE OVERCROWDED
AND, THEY TRY TO MEET
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DEMANDED TO DO
MORE.
IT'S A 36% JUMP, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT MADE GOOD ON
THE PRESIDENT'S PROMISE TO CUT
OFF $530 MILLION IN AID IT TO
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS AND
EL SALVADOR.
AND THE ABILITY TO REDUCE THE
FLOW OF MIGRANTS.
>> WHEN YOU SAY COME ON, DON'T
COAL TO OUR COUNTRY.
WE ALSO HAVE PROBLEMS.
NO, YOUR PROBLEMS HAVE NO
COMPARISON TO OURS.
>> SO IS THIS A ONE-TIME EFFORT
OR SUSTAINABLE?
AT THE U.S. SHOULD KNOW
SOMETHING IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS